هي ما كانت تنتهي هدنه الاربعه والعشرين
ساعه في السودان حتى عاد صوت الرصاص
والقذائف الى ما كان عليه فقد تجددت
الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم
وتمحورت بحسب مراسل العربيه في وسط وغرب
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان مشيرا الى استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه خلال الاشتباكات في
محيط جسر الحلفايه في مدينه بحري شمالي
الخرطوم حيث توالت الانباء عن سيطره الجيش
عليه
وقد اكد مراسل العربيه سماع عدوي مدافع
ثقيله وتصاعد السنه اللهب والدخان وتحليقا
للطيران الحربي منذ ساعات الصباح مؤكدا ان
طيران الجيش قصف تمركزات لقوات الدعم
السريع في مدن الخرطوم درمان
المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كانت قد ذكرت ان فرق
الحمايه التابعه للجنه في السودان تستقبل
اتصالات دائمه للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان
لافراد من العائلات السودانيه منذ بدء
الصراع قبل حوالي شهرين
وبحسب المتحدثه لم تتوقف البلاغات حتى
الان مع مرور كل يوم مع استمرار عمليات
البحث عن المفقودين المبلغ عنهم
وشددت ايضا على ان عمليه التقصدونها عوائق
عديده ابرزها الاقتتال المستمر وشح
الامكانيات والموارد الطبيه حيث تعيق
عمليات التعرف على الجثمين او انتشارها
اذهب الى اقليم دارفور ينضم الي من هناك
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد الاشتباكات والمواجهات واين تركزت في
الساعات القليله الماضيه
دارفور حتى هذه الساعات يشهد هدوء ولا
تجدد
للاشتباكات بحسب ما يرد الينا من مدن
الاقليم
المتفرغه لكن الوضع الانساني في غلندر فور
مازال كما هو لم يتحسن في
مدينه الفاشر تشهد نزوح كبير قادم من
محليه كتم التي شهدت قتال بين الجيش
والدعم السريع خلال الايام الماضيه وسيطر
على هذه المدينه الدعم السريع كما
في بيانه ايضا هنالك ولايه غرب دارفور
مدينه الجنينه ما زالت الاتصالات مقطوعه
تماما عن مدينه الجنينه ما زال الوضع
الانساني كما هو لم يتحسن لا تستطيع فروغ
الانقاذ او المنظمات الدخول الى مدينه
الجنينه نسبه لما تشهده الطرق من عمليات
التفلت وعمليات نهب وعمليات قتال مستمر في
محيط مدينه الجنينه والطرق المؤدي اليها
وحتى داخل مدينه الجنينه نزوح كبير ولجوء
كبير جدا
كما ذكرت النزوح من الفاشر باتجاه اي
مناطق يعني النازحون عندما ينزحون سواء من
الفاشر ايضا من الجنينه الى اي مناطق وهل
هذه المنا طق التي ينزحون اليها هي مناطق
امنه
نعم هو النزوح من الفاشر يعني كان من
الاحياء
الغير امنه الى الاحياء الامنه مستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه بالمدارس وبمواقع كثيره في
مدينه الفاشر يعني اضافه الى هذا النزوح
هنالك نزوح من محليه كتم التي
نزحوا الى داخل مدينه الفاشر هنالك لجان
لواء نازحين من مدينه الفاشر داخل المدارس
وداخل الاماكن العامه في مدينه الفاشر حتى
هذه اللحظه هنالك ايضا نزوح حول مدينه كتم
نعلم بان الاحداث التي دارت في مدينه كتم
تاثر بها كثيرا معسكر يسمى كساب هو يتبع
للنازحين في الفتره الماضيه فروا الى
القرى المجاوره والى مواقع كثيره مجاوره
لمحليه كتب بغرض الاحتماء بالمناطق الامنه
حتى
من يتابع اوضاع هؤلاء هل هم متركون لحالهم
لمصيرهم ام لا ثمت منظمات او جمعيات تتابع
احوالهم خصوصا في مرحله نزوحهم
نعم معظم معظم الانشطه هنا في غليم دارفور
هي فقط انشطه اهليه مجتمعيه شبابيه تطوعيه
تدخل لتحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه وتدخل ايضا
لاجلال جرحه وتدخل ايضا لمعالجه بعض
القضايا الانسانيه لا يوجد منظمات ابدا
حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك يعني حركه لكن هذه
الحركه حتى الان نسبه للتفلتات الكبيره
ونسبه لحاله السيوله الامنيه في اوليمب
دارفور لا تستطيع المنظمات حمايه ابدا
اطقمها والذين يعملون معها خلال هذه
الفتره هنالك فقط حراك اهلي حراك مجتمعي
شبابي لهذه الاحداث ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
اقليم دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو علامه شكرا
جزيلا لك صالح على كل هذه المتابعه
الى اندرمان الان ينضم الي الصحفيه
المقداد حسن مقداد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
الاشتباكات والمواجهات سواء في ام درمان
او في الخرطوم بحري واين تركز التحديدا في
الساعات الماضيه خصوصا جسر الحلفايه
والكلام انه الجيش تمكن من السيطره تماما
على هذه النقطه
تحياتي اليك طالب والى المجاهدين نعم
الاشتباكات منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى هذه
اللحظه نحن نستمع الى الطائرات الحربيه
تحلق في سماء العاصمه المثلثه بمدنها
الثلاث وكذلك الطيران الاستطلاع نستمع
ايضا الى دوري المضادات الارضيه التي تتبع
لقوات الدعم السريع باتجاه هذه المقاتلات
الحربيه التي تتبع للجيش السوداني هذه
المقاتلات قصفت صباح هذا اليوم مناطق
متفرقه في العاصمه الخرطوم ابتداء من وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم ومركزها حيث شارع الغابه
والمنطقه الصناعيه وهذه المنطقه كما
تابعنا في الايام الماضيه انها تتواجد
فيها قوات الدعم السريع ايضا القصف امتد
حتى شرق النيل بمدينه بحري في تلك المنطقه
ايضا تتواجد قوات الدعم السريع بكثافه
وجنوبا في مدينه ام درمان هذا القصف ايضا
طال مناطق الصالحه التي هي تتبع لها قوات
الدعم السريع باعتبار ان هنالك معسكر
لقوات الدعم السريع في تلك المنطقه ايضا
كان القصف المدفعي من تمركزات الجيش
السوداني بشمال مدينه ام درمان يستهدف
مناطق متفرقه ايضا كما ذكرت ان جسر
الحلفايه من الجسور الاستراتيجيه دارت فيه
اشتباكات عنيفه صباح هذا اليوم وتابعنا
كثير من الفيديوهات التي بثها النشطون
وايضا تحدثنا الى مصادر عسكريه تحدثت عن
سيطره قوات الجيش السوداني على ذلك الجزء
الان وفي هذه اللحظه استمع الى طائره
حربيه مقاتله تحلق في سماء مدينه ام درمان
ربما هي الان بصدد تنفيذ غاره جويه على
على بعض المناطق الاستراتيجيه في مدينه ام
درمان هذا القصف ايضا الذي يعني ابتدى
صباح هذا اليوم راح ضحيته مدنيون في جنوب
الحزام او ما يعرف بمناطق الازهري جراء
القصف الذي يقع عشوائيا على منازل
المواطنين باعتبار ان هذه الاشتباكات تكون
وسط احيانا تكون وسط احياء بها
بغداد هل سجل يعني
وضعنا موضوع جسر الحلفايه جانبا هل سجل اي
تقدم نوعي لطرف على طرف اخر في الساعات
الاربعه وعشرين الماضيه ام لا ستاتيكو ما
زال قائما يعني لا يعني لم يتقدم اي فريق
على اخر او اي طرف على اخر
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه ربما هو الصوت الاعلى
للمقاتلات وللاشتباكات ولم يعني تسجل اي
جهه رسميه بيانات صادره من الجيش السوداني
او من الدعم السريع بتقدمها في منطقه او
تاخرها في اخرى وبالتالي نحن ننتظر ان
تصدر هذه البيانات ونحاول ان نتواصل مع
القيادات العسكريه في عما اذا كانت تقدم
الجيش السوداني او تقدم الدعم السريع في
منطقه هنالك فيديوهات بثها ناشطون وتحدثنا
الى ما صادر عسكريه تتحدث عن ان الجيش
السوداني وصل من شمال مدينه بحري حتى شارع
المدينه حتى شارع المعونه جنوبا جنوب
مدينه مدينه بحري وهذا الشارع هو ربما من
الشوارع التي شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في
الايام الاولى وسيطرت عليه قوات الدعم
السريع والان المصادر العسكريه تحدث الينا
ان هنالك تقدم للجيش السوداني في هذا
الشارع بمدينه بحري لكن بالمقابل قوات
الدعم السريع ما تزال تنشر فيديوهات عبر
صفحتها الرسميه بانها يعني استحولت على
على مركبات تتبع للجيش السوداني انها
سيطرت على عده مناطق دخلت اليها قوات
الجيش السوداني صباح هذا اليوم وبالتالي
نحن ايضا هنا في حرب بيانات اعلاميه وحرب
اعلام يحتاج الى توضيح بالنسبه للجهتين
لكن على العموم الجيش السوداني منذ صباح
هذا اليوم كثف غاراته وكثف هجومه بصوره
واضحه وكبيره جدا في رقعه جغرافيه واسعه
من العاصمه الخرطوم في شرقها وغربها
ووسطها وفي مدينه ام درمان ومدينه بحري
منهم درمان الصحفي المقداد حسن شكرا جزيلا
لك مقداد على كل هذه المتابعه من داخل
مستودع الغاز
جانا
والمحروقات
في المستودعات
شرق الكلاكله من داخل المستودعات
غاز بالجمله نهي بسرقه كل حاجه كل حاجه
المستودعات فاتحه بنزين جائز راس الله
يكون في عونك يا شعبي الله يكون في عونك
يا شعبي
قاعدين في نص الدعامه والناس دي كلها على
روقه ماخذين راحته مكاتب المستودعات
وكاتب المستودعات
لحاله المستودعات من الداخل حال
المستودعات
المزيد الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات